hi there okay
well we are doing a design review of new
functionality for version 13
related to biosequences
so let's dig in here so we have this
function biosequence
that i'm sure doesn't represent those
weird new bacteria or something we just
found last week or whatever
or maybe it does
with them
with some different uh
uh coding scheme but but now what are
these things indicated in red
the new things
well those are the new ones
okay
um
so what what should i be reading here is
that other examples to look at
yeah it should be yeah anything in red
anything marked with an f particularly
these red examples here these are the
things you should be looking at
okay so we've got a bunch of new names
so here's my question
where is
if i just want to get a list of all of
these
is there a data repository entry with
these or am i scraping the documentation
page
there's a biosequences type entity
with with these properties also defined
does that does it say that somewhere
here
it should
it would
it why doesn't it say it right under the
table
i think that's a convention we should
start to have
but this is how you get this table do
you understand what i'm saying yes
okay
here we have various instances where
this is the case
right
okay
so this is stuff we already had was
these these things but again we should
so these are accessible from some entity
property is that correct that's right
yes
loud abbreviations for dna what does
this mean i don't understand what this
means what is d
what does that mean
so these are our standard abbreviations
also
a and c and so forth and sometimes users
will have sequences in these for
particularly for the peptides and so
these are going to be supported as an
alternate form of input
remember
they are easier to remember than the
single letters
yes
so wait a second so so when you hold on
in a string that has an a in it you can
say d a doe d edo d aido instead of aaa
is that correct
am i understanding correctly you can
substitute for the capital a you can
substitute this d
thing
that's right for a dna sequence yes
okay
but why don't we say agc i don't
understand what i understand the
left-hand side and the right-hand side
here i don't understand this
the left-hand side is the canonical one
that we used so far okay but then so
this is a this is if i might say so a
wrong table i mean this table here
okay okay
above clearly spares it out
except standards abbreviations in place
of sequence letters i see
allowed abbreviations possible possible
i wouldn't say it loud i said possible
abbreviations
included
um
okay fine
but i understand the left-hand side
i notice i think this table is the wrong
way round
right
right i mean this is because this is
saying this is a new abbreviation which
is equivalent to this
but are you also saying where are you
saying
that
i mean given that you're giving this you
might as well say what it actually is i
don't know scene or whatever
there's a table of that below i'll merge
them yes
where's the table of that
um
i think we should keep them separated
the one is kind of syntax the other one
is kind of going explaining something
then i would well
i don't know i i i think if it says a
and then the alternative form
you know d a doe
and then yeah
alanine it makes sense and i mean that
way
i mean i would even consider
but i think we should not mix with the
meta characters
that's fine but then these are these are
not meta okay fine the nutter characters
are separately up here
and then these are
um
base pair abbreviations which is what
they are peptide and somewhere down here
peptide abbreviations are base pair
abbreviations for dna are it's not an
abbreviation for rna it's for base pairs
bases
right that's what we should say
and then we should say
i think these should be in the you know
in the kind of the typewriter the code
font even though they're not in quotes
so should this be
um and and then we should say what it is
but i think it's it's a little bit
unclear these are both possible
abbreviations i mean i think there's an
argument that this could say a comma edo
and then on the right-hand side whatever
the thing is alanine
whatever am i making sense
i would keep them in different columns
okay well so lawrence then how are we
going to make it clear
that this is something you can type in
it's be helped by the font of the
general perhaps
okay all right so anyway so these are
okay so now
the following bonds
you know the style okay
can additionally be connected through
given what does that mean what does that
mean
you you normally have a sequence and the
elements of the sequence are connected
to it rather by a strong covalent bond
but then you can take some non-local one
include them together with weaker ones
i understand but what does that actually
look like syntactically
there's a third argument which lists a
form where how
well then why don't you give that
pattern here
before you go in and say di sulphur
bonds where is that pattern supposed to
go down
you hit it
it was it was here right
yeah
okay so
before you go
okay i think that you should remind
people here what the signature is what
the form of the thing with bonds is
and then here if this is i don't
understand what this is this this is
specifically
is this an is this what you type
or is this possible
what's that what is possible as it was
possible so for example a disulfide
bridge can only connect one sustained
message with another you can't use it
for
tell me what you actually type
go down and look at the examples
well
it'll be underneath the uh sequences
from entities there will be a bond
section
there we go sequence of the bonds at the
bottom
okay you have got to show that in
okay this was utterly obscure
utterly utterly obscure and what you're
saying is what you're defining there is
which
possible
but this is what the usage message
pretty clearly spares out
in my opinion okay by the time you've
had a detailed section that's that long
you've got to repeat something
okay
you can't expect people to understand
without that
and and here i mean i'll mostly just
look at the example but what you're
saying here is that the one four here
you should say in biosequence blah blah
blah blah blah
the indices 1 4 must correspond to
blah blah blah blah blah you see what
i'm saying
because those 1 and 4 must refer to a c
a t or whatever it is and not for
something else correct
must maybe it's not quite the right word
do
well but if i
okay
what possible the one and the four
that means the a and the t are connected
by a multi-hydrogen bond is that correct
that's right okay
okay so but if i chose to connect those
two c's you know if i said bond 2 3
multi hydrogen that would not be a
possible chemical thing is that correct
that could work i mean it would be an
unconventional multihydrogen okay but so
what what is the statement that you're
making about what works and what doesn't
work right so in the above the disulfide
and the
the other one those ones are constrained
okay so fine if i type disulfide there i
want to know what does it do if i tell
it to make a disulfide bond between two
things which can't have a disulfide bond
between them
uh
it it will fail to evaluate and will not
be true from biosequence queue
okay but so it will it will give a
message presumably
tell me it gives a message right
it gives a message
okay all right so let's go back up here
to what you're saying
okay this is hopelessly obscure
hopelessly hopelessly obscure
first of all you say in and then give
the signature for biosequence with a
bond thing in this
the
the following constraints you know there
are the following constraints on the
you know
you know whatever you call them b sub i
or something which are the the bond
indices so to speak the indices there am
i making sense yes
which is the the line after the green
bar
um
i'm sorry the line
like there's a we could instead and then
the next one
one specified in the form connect this
with this
to make the chemicals corresponding to
the string positions i and j those
should be italic yeah
through a bond
we usually say have the specified type
when the word is actually tight but but
um
specified
okay first of all you should say
in and then give the to give the overall
form
but
so
and i don't know why he's so funny kind
of typewriter characters here
should that i mean this just means c can
connect to c u to u etc right that's
right and so you should say in here the
i j
okay i mean you've got to say in this
form given this
these are the constraints on what the
inj can refer to in the actual
biosequence right
right okay so so basically change to all
of the cells that's what i'm thinking
yes
and don't use two-way rule
in that table it'll be very confusing
this was my suggestion i take
responsibility well okay but if you're
going to use it just don't use it as a
typewriter thing use it with arrows
okay i i would think this should be much
higher up i mean it's it's obvious to
anybody who does this for a living but
to people who don't
this kind of explains roughly what's
going on
maybe
i mean otherwise
and and each one of these as i said
should have something underneath it that
says
this
you know in parens probably
this table is available as
you get what i'm saying yeah
okay
and in fact we should we should be doing
that
elsewhere in documentation for other
things too okay so so what functionality
so this is
okay i want to see the bio plot stuff
because that's going to be much more
colorful
okay
okay so can i run this
be able to yeah okay i don't understand
this don't do it this way biosequence
plot of biosequence don't define a
variable just for amusement value
there's no reason to do that please
don't do that
i think we've been through this like 18
times before
d do you understand yeah i understand
why why were you doing it that way
what was the point
i just
understand was there a reason you did
that or not
no particular reason i'll fix it you do
say that in a lot of live streams but i
don't know if it's a lot with john and
michael in them
no no no he ha i definitely feel that i
do it myself a lot that's why i
sometimes oversee it i find it much more
natural it first define a thing and then
do things with it
yeah i mean when you just do one thing
though it's a little weird
it's more than a little weird okay so
now we're going to try this
put that in there as it should be
okay so now
okay why does it have a little wiggle
wobble at the beginning
why isn't it just straight
because we use graph embedded existing
coffin buildings
okay really is that the right thing to
do why is it just a straight line it's
dna
okay we could have a special case for
this but for more general we would have
to re-implement embeddings
no i understand but but okay so look
if i say
i'm gonna make this a crab
don't they have just a and t i can't
remember
if i just say biosequence plot with just
the letters will it work or not
it will not
okay does it give a sentient error
message
no it probably just doesn't evaluate
okay so this is a
amusing
but unuseful what the heck happened
there
position 17 okay but what's what's that
bond there
why is there a great big bond
in the case here where is it gray here
and small and great big here we noticed
this earlier
okay
and and if this is a graph
why am i not no no no no it's not a
cause
it explicitly says the result is a
graphics
okay
it uses the embedding of carbs to get a
layout
okay okay
all right so here
what
this is getting very colorful but what's
it doing here
okay so this is a hybrid strand most of
the time
okay so for example if i do
that's lovely if i do
um
uh
what if i do sequence alignment is there
anything useful i'll get from that
no not for this case no
and we don't yet have visualization for
sequence alignment is that true
there's a wfr for it but not built in
okay that seems like the thing people i
mean these pictures other than for small
cases
where they're sort of useful for
textbook purposes these are not
particularly useful for
for
actual presentation are they or am i no
i disagree okay the so-called airport
plots for rna are very popular okay all
right okay
so so let me pick a piece of rna
so let's say i
um
let me rna if i this
okay what what happened here is that
is that useful or is that i mean doesn't
the rna doesn't it curl up in a
well-known way
amount of possibly call ups and be
honest working on a wfr to compute them
so now you would have to add secondary
bonds and then you get the plot of the
one specified
i see okay okay and by the way as um
dan is pointing out on the live stream
this that arrow head looks really weird
yes uh it's still a discussion this
design not yet okay all right okay
and so
in terms of the three prime five prime
arrow e that's so there's a well-defined
direction
which everybody understands for dna
right which would yeah let's just say
yeah okay
okay
well that looks lovely and this is done
with graph embedding you're saying
that's right
okay
and are there you know how would
somebody typically get an ornate
multi-stranded etc thing
there's uh
there's a notation that we'll be
supporting
for um
for kind of how these groups fold in on
each other there's an example of that in
the neat examples section
a bit
right i don't understand that
i guess
so there's there's a notation with
brackets and and one which kind of
unpack into
forms like that join like this
wait wait so it's like a smiles like
thing for
for the string here is that correct it's
right it's two strings yeah
yeah
so you have a string mentioning the
main
uh the main components and then the so
called that bracket notation depicts the
bonding
and so what's our format for
representing that
now we evaluate it to the list of
extricated bonds
okay but what's the input format
is it a single string or is it two
strings or is it a string with an extra
string tacked on at the end the string
for the sequence and then a string for
the bonds
so two strings in a list is that right
that's right
yes but is that consistent with what
else we're doing
sorry i i would say it should be like we
have biosequence of type comma and then
there should be string one string two
and then string two represents the bonds
which evaluates to the list of ones
i mean this we can discuss if there's an
additional curly list around or not
this will not be in this version so
no i think
john was
wait a minute so just let me understand
there is an additional notation which
is positionally related to the first
string yes or no to secondly
no this string here oh this one yes
it is positionally related to that and
it has a bunch of parentheses in it
and so why is it that so it is a
secondary overlay on that string it's
another thing full of parens is that
correct
it doesn't have numbers in it it has
positional parentheses is that correct
yes what does it look like give me an
example yeah there is one in one of the
other notebooks as in a comment
which one
buy a sequence
i think it doesn't buy a sequence
it's in the uh
the bond section of the examples
where's that
it's always it'll be in uh
it's the second one
oh yeah okay so it's this creature here
that's right yes that bracket
okay so you're proposing here a third
argument to biosequence no the the the
same one as the explicit bonds
oh i see
i see because it represents i guess that
makes perfect sense yeah that's fine
but but probably to argument with a list
around
should do the same um really
can you do much i mean because are you
sure okay no i mean this cannot be a
hybrid strength this list of parents
okay
so but hold on i mean uh be careful
though right because the two argument
form with a list of strings in the
second
has a meaning right oh oh you're right
you're right
i forgot but if there is a list in that
second argument what third argument bond
specification could there be
what is the meaning with the first and
second argument
it's it's a it's a hybrid strand so
there would be
hybrid strand bonds in the third
argument
okay but are they specifiable with the
start bracket notation or not
no
you don't necessarily use that bracket
for mixtures
usually for your peer rna per dna
although there's no ambiguity along the
total lengths of the strand so it could
it would just
you know
if there was a a list of of four letters
followed by another list of four letters
and then you said okay here's a bond
list eight characters long
there's no trouble about what they
correspond to
okay
all right
next question i mean in all the stuff we
have here with all these hybrid
strandery things and so on is it the
case that we have now covered basically
every
configuration of dna that people
realistically generate and rna and so on
that people realistically generate in
the lab
i
my impression is yeah we're doing pretty
well
certainly our our collaborators have
looked that over and we're covering what
they cover
okay so
john must correct me
just what what i read as a layman
it should cover a fair fraction of what
is a sequence mean is minor meaning a
linear arrangement but people do
things where
they branch and are no longer is secrets
yeah so we don't have the branching
stuff yet that's
way way far away but
the sequential stuff that mostly occur
what people see in nature those are
supported but in nature dna does not
branch
is that correct or has some weird
bacteria there bacteria with the weird
rna motifs
we're not doing that right now
okay
okay
okay
all right so
what does this do when you just feed it
things it doesn't like to eat
i mean all these things here if i give
this
yeah okay i think it should give a
message
okay
and and in something like this if i take
a thing like this
whatever this is
and i say biosecurity so it's
going back so
maybe for an expedited string but not
say for a symbol i agree okay good just
making sure okay okay all right so
there's a magnificent object
okay now i'm going to just make a change
here
oh it did something okay
so i mean i can just go with wild
abandon and turn this into
that oh splaperoo
okay that's not good enough it's gotta
have some kind of message saying that
that's
out of range
okay now why did that not work
no clue
so it's got to have something that says
why it didn't work
am i making sense i totally agreed
wowie look at that creature oh boy he's
wild
gee it whatever
now just feed that to your average
bacterium or whatever it is okay so what
happened here and why are the bonds so
long
and why do the bonds look so thick
compared to the actual um
uh
bases
yeah the
thicker bonds are still primary
structure so you can see some thinner
ones as well okay but why are these dots
so small
this looks like a bug to me yeah
yeah that is for sure
i can't see that
well it took me more than a minute to
find it i i guess the reason is that the
scale return from graph embedding is too
large
yeah you see there are like
it's pretty much in the middle there are
two bases very near together they set
the scale and then i'm sending this in
chat just so you have the code yep thank
you okay thank you
um
oh look at that
now if i were to just say graph 3d of
this just for fun it's not going to work
it's not a graph
this is very jolly
i mean i don't know what it means
and what's happening here is very weird
i mean is this a reasonable
representation of what it physically is
or is this just a random visual
representation
it's a schematic representation uh
making it look like what it's supposed
to look like in bacteria for example is
a whole different catalyst
my understanding is that they are
overall
folded in a non-trivial 3d way
yeah
right
okay
okay well this is very very nice
okay
um
okay
all right what are those
oh that's just a choice
this is like user-made one
i see i see
that's nice
these are the entities
other than this horrifying well i guess
you're doing two of them but
ah sigh
but too far down i think it's about
it's below fivefold
the
um
what is that okay so this could be a
molecule so if i take this
puppy let us let us do it
okay i take that thing
and i say molecule of that
and it goes crunch oh fluff fluff fluff
fluff because
you have meadows
what do you mean
oh i need to i need to concretify these
things where where are my matters
i don't see
well
they're complete things
no matter
there's no matter scene
interest
i think that's the wrong error message
anyway
in this case
oh is it's a problem that
they couldn't figure out the bonds
that's
that's a possibility
but indeed
generation purposes because
the hydrogen bonds aren't really
depicted in a molecule object
but are these hydrogen bonds by default
yes because these are nucleic nucleic
acids
[Music]
okay
so this just seems to be a bug
okay but if i were to take something
like this
yeah that should work
that's challenging
i know
the size i would
i wouldn't i don't have confidence that
that's going to yeah
exactly
i know that's why i'm trying it
okay
any chance of a progress monitor
yes it is uh so once i i learned how to
uh to do that kind of um talking back
and forth between the the the underlying
code and the in the time
um i do believe it's possible i just
don't know but i mean so there's
something definite that is going on here
i mean there's a there's a known process
that it is following right and it it is
iterative you i did insert uh the the
ability to um abort so it so it is in
principle possible to uh to call back to
the title
right and there uh there is a a like max
attempts an internal parameter that i
set to like
some some smaller number so that it
doesn't uh just keep going on and on
forever oh yeah but that's a nice thing
wow
mostly the problem with molecules like
is they are too
uh because fluffy they're too flappy the
coordinates of them is nothing
but 2d layouts that's fine
right now i mean you could write a um
let's see a smarter embedding routine
the 3d embedding routine that we
generally use involved has some
randomness to it
you try and um
well molecules
right right but uh so if but if you
wanted to embed something like this you
might it might be uh easier to first
embed the one base and then uh add
something onto it and then iteratively
build up the 3d structure rather than
well okay that's an issue for how the
algorithm works for 3d structure i'm
surprised there's not something already
existing from back in the 70s to make
helices
out of these oh there's actually a
um i think jan pointed out a long time
ago there's there's a nice uh uh program
just if you want to make a helix that is
like geometric you could provide it uh
well maybe we should give that as an
option for molecule plot
for a case like this
right for people who just want to curl
this in helix
yeah
yeah i'll uh look into that uh so it's
it involves a as you say bob like an
older program that uh that you can
interface with that's
i'm sure they did it back in the 70s um
when they were first starting to to to
look at these things on things like
evans and sutherland equipment
but uh you know we should be able to
find something and implement our own
language not rely on you know ancient
fortran
yes right
okay
all right let's take a look here all
right so we've got biosequence plot
we've had a look at biosequence modify
um just needs the corresponding
additions to deal with the new
structures okay
so add a bond
biosequence modify okay
all right move bonds inwards what does
that mean
that means that
if uh you have bonds on the sequence
collection level but they could be
specified at a
you know emotion one of the one of the
inner sequences move that bond
to that sequence
there's got to be a better word than
this that's just a totally obscure thing
move bonds inwards sounds like
uh bob is just commenting on their live
stream about videos of the kinesin
molecule walking along that's what i
move bonds inwards gives me that thought
what does it mean it means
what what is the point you have
you have you have a sequence collection
you use the three argument
index to specify but it could be
specified by two arguments and this is
two argument indices wait a minute
so give me an example yeah like in the
right upper on your right uh
notebook you see you see the hybrid but
assume it's at the lowest level then we
don't need every time to repeat the one
repeat which one the first one in the
point on the first argument
means take the first of this the second
of this and then the second base
yep but assume it is already in a
smaller one then move it into one of the
bio sequences
maybe if we look at an example in the
biosequence modify page yeah better
it's a simple example move bonds inward
we have two little pieces and we specify
it looking from the outside but you
could look at it from the inside
i'm seriously confused here okay so
we've got this thing it's a hybrid
strand of a dna and an rna
and this specifies that
one two
specifies the bond say at the outer
biosequence level
by outer we mean
that occurrence
of the
biosequence
okay but that's this one two is
referring to the c and the g is that a c
and the u is that correct
this one two is a bond between the first
letter in the dna and the second letter
in the rna is that correct
no
no
the first the first biosequence and then
the second tail and then take the
first one again and take oh okay i get
it i get it so this is in fact because
this is only referring to a one it's
only referring to the first biosequence
it can't be boy
move pawns inward that's the most
obscure
oh my god
we knew you wouldn't be a big fan of
this name
so what is it really doing
it's
so the bond is now associated with the
dna
at a particular hybrid strand
okay so it's dehydrated strandifying it
it's putting it it's still a hybrid
strength
it's still a hybrid strand because it
has both the dna and the rna yeah but
basically what it's saying is if the
bonds are specifically within
a single
a single
biosequence
or something a single sequence then it's
putting them there yeah that's right yes
is that the only thing it does or kind
of move in one level and there are two
levels altogether or something and three
levels altogether
yeah it can move all of all the
different levels it can move from
sequence collection to hybrid to motif
all the way down
so one point here is that
this is a purely syntactic thing it is
not changing the actual structure right
i mean adding a bond is absolutely
changing in structure
that's right right but this one here
is like
eyes
it's some
uh
the um
this is this disjunctive normal form for
brilliant expressions
it's the same entities it just changes
the form
right
well i think it needs a word that makes
it clear
that it isn't actually changing our
thing
right so it needs to say
two innermost point representations
that's closer
could it be thought of as simplified
no
no
maybe one direction but not the other
how about innermost bond representation
or and then canonicalize becomes
canonical bond representation or
something canonical representation of
something
canonical representation innermost bond
representation outermost bond
representation
those all work
i think that's okay and at least one
doesn't think was actually changing the
molecule
um
let's see okay all right let me see
okay
there's some questions on our live
stream here the question from mq
is this when is this release scheduled
for we wish we knew but um it uh we are
certainly planning it solidly in this
calendar year
um but things can happen
um
crazy things can happen
but
uh that's our plan
in time for the christmas season
hopefully
um the real life representations of a
lot of fire sequences
what
it depends on yes it depends on yes
because it was yesterday archive paper
they were predicting we will one more
time see a tenfold increase in
transmissivity based on various machine
learning techniques applied to all
existing versions before
well i have to dig back into those big
immunology books that i'm reading
um
let's see
cut off asking can it wiggle and rotate
the answer was no not at this time right
i mean this is a two dimensional these
are all purely two-dimensional and we
don't think it's we don't have a way i
mean we could be using graph 3d to make
a 3d version of this and biosequence
plot could conceivably have a second
argument that would make a nominally 3d
version of this correct
in the maybe they'd start with the wfr
okay fine
um
because the danger there would i mean
would be to try and um
people think it's real and it isn't real
yes
right i mean this looks awfully real
world-ish this thing here and i wonder
if there's a way to indicate even in its
visual form that it is a schematic
i would say the bigger those circles are
relative to the bonds the more it looks
like a schematic
when we see something like this that's
obviously schematic
when we see something like this it's got
this nice little curve that doesn't that
seems more like it's a physical
representation but it's probably exactly
the opposite what happens yeah
what do you mean that in the case where
like this one what you have on the
screen that's probably very unphysical
because of this distance things yeah
the other ones the distance are maybe at
least locally sensible
right but but i still think that you
need to have the the actual letters much
bigger here even if that means that you
have to specify things in the graph
layout so that it knows to avoid and so
on so it knows to push these out all
those kinds of things yes
um
okay
uh suggestion that it makes a crunch
crunch noise when it's uh computing
the very first computer i used back in
the 1970s used to make noises as it
computed
it's kind of gone out of fashion i think
um
the uh
um
calais is asking can we test protein
chains and find out where they pass
through each other
um
this is a protein folding
you know there's been lots of progress
with machine learning on that in recent
times including by
a
former employee of ours uh who's now a
professor at columbia um
uh muhammad al-qarashi who's done lots
of great work on that and has been uh
uh interacting with us on this stuff and
hopefully we'll um
hopefully we'll have interesting things
to show in that area i mean it has been
something out of range
for
sort of everyday computation but it
seems like it's coming in range
um it's a nice article three weeks ago
in science
was one by muhammad not not long ago
that's what i mean yeah yeah right
the
um
the uh
okay let's see
um
is the bio-molecular sequences flexible
enough to support
non-canonical base pairs the answer is
yes
we have lovely stuff for
the um
where do those critters live that the um
the
hatch emoji
as opposed to where do those things live
does anybody know emoji is actually an
artificial
construction they added um
i think it's an extended biosequence
type example in here
okay
okay anyway but we support all known
reasonable
rates
right
i was talking about microtubules that is
a different level of bio-object than
what we're dealing with here these are
just molecules i guess why what are
microtubules are they are they single
molecules are they like you know
flagella of bacteria and things
that are just single protein type
objects
anybody know that would be a bob type of
question i mean
i don't know um they're definitely uh
protonatious uh i i doubt very much
they're a single molecule but they're
probably composed
of aggregates uh just reading the
[Music]
yeah uh would they be possibly made up
of actin or myosin or something like
that uh
that kind of would make sense tubulin
for microtubules yes
um
okay let's see
anything else we need to look at here
it's looking lovely
function plot
q you're you're fine with the q or you
want to vape i hate the q but i hate the
q but if you think we need the cube put
in the q i mean this stuff is all still
experimental i think all those kind of q
functions for testing validity
should be
uh
folded into a single thing but i mean
that's a bigger discussion there's
probably 20 of those things
at least
right so you know time to make a
systematic approach
um
okay it should be everything
right for people who are paying
attention to live streams we have gosh
we have two more today my gosh
i'm living in public a lot well uh 3 30
p.m eastern time there's a science and
technology q a for kids and others
and five o'clock eastern time is a
design review for trees
uh that is abstract trees not biological
ones
that will be for a different year
okay um
good stuff all right thanks thank you